[Music]
[Applause]
nbc football night america analyst and
two-time super bowl champ and somebody
who should be in the hall of fame uh
rodney harrison he'll be part of the nfl
kickoff thursday that'll be next
thursday as the buccaneers host the
cowboys coverage begins at seven eastern
football night in america on nbc and
peacock and uh rodney harrison the
former great defensive back joining us
on the program how are you rod you look
like you want to hit somebody
i'm a little down right now dan i got
some just got some disturbing news a
former teammate of mine david patton i
guess he was involved in a motorcycle
accident that took his life um i heard
it that his wife is in critical
condition
i just got the news this morning maybe
about 20 minutes ago and i'm just i'm
devastated he was such a great man
a great man of god i'm a great leader in
our locker room man and i'm just i'm
just heartbroken
would you rather do the interview
another day no i'm gonna finish it off
dan i'm okay buddy i appreciate you
um
can i bring you back to the 0304
patriots when you guys repeated because
there's been that you know that talk
with tom and trying to do this again
with tampa bay what was the key thing
about that going into the 04 season
that
belichick reminded you or
uh that that was the most important
thing about hey this is what we do and
we can win it again
well you know after after the season we
never really discussed the super bowl
the biggest thing that he said hey this
is a totally different team it's a new
season no one talks about repeating we
focus on one game at a time and really
he set the tone
um for that mindset
and you know as much as we wanted to go
forward and think about oh man we got a
chance to repeat he always reminded us
but also we had so many great veterans
in that locker room that constantly the
teddy brewskis of the world willie
mcginnis myself richard seymour all
those guys constantly reminded not only
the veteran players but also the rookies
that hey you know we haven't won
anything i mean this year is his own
individual year and you have to focus on
that
what do you think brady is telling his
teammates
one game at a time
don't worry about last year all those
different things but he's definitely
letting them know like look guys we can
win this because the mindset is
different like with the patriots you
could really never be outwardly
expressive as far as hey we want to
repeat but with tampa bay i mean it's a
new regime it's a lot of younger players
um with you know a great variety of some
veteran players so i think they openly
will claim that hey they feel like they
can repeat definitely i think tom that's
definitely in tom brady's mind
when you don't have athleticism you
don't lose athleticism
so is brady basically the same
quarterback as you had when you were
there with him in new england
yeah and i think he has a whole heck of
a lot of weapons around him i mean you
look at the weapons he's got mike evans
if he continues to go on the path that
he's gone he's gonna be a hall of famer
antonio brown
arguably is a hall of famer bronk is a
hall of famer and they have that run
game with the offensive line the veteran
coaching staff that made some great
adjustments the second part of the
second half of the season and tom his
eagerness his
his um
you know his desire to be the greatest
and tom's always looking for that
motivation and um i got some funny
stories but i can't tell him today about
tom and just that motivation but yeah
man he's he's really motivated and he's
ready to go wait wait wait you can't say
you have funny stories but then you
can't tell if it takes too long it takes
too long dan i mean like on a different
podcast or something like that this is
the dan patrick show you don't have 30
minutes to be waiting wasting your time
with me all right all right well i know
you used to frustrate him in practice
and you know because he was going
against a pretty good secondary and and
you know brady was
ultra competitive even in practice
yeah he was and you know the bad part
about today's nfl everyone's so caught
up in an athletic quarterback well tom
brady won the most super bowls without
being athletic if you're smart you're a
great decision maker um your teammates
believe in you and that's the biggest
thing with tom tom never wanted to
disappoint his teammates he never always
wanted to make sure that he wasn't the
reason why we lost that he wanted to be
the reason why we won and um you know
just that mindset over 20-something
years man it's just amazing to see how
everything has um transpired for them
did mack jones win the job or cam newton
lose the job i think mack jones won the
job that's why i had nothing negative to
say about cam i think you know you look
at mac and everything that he did he
came in the first game they put him in a
no huddle offense and let him just dink
and dunk let him throw the ball down the
field decide who and you watch him play
i mean the kid is accurate he's smart
he's so poised
and you know he'll he's not afraid to
get in somebody's face i just love the
kid and i think that it was a i never
thought that cam would get
um cut but the fact that he got cut just
shows me that cam has a big big
personality and you can't have somebody
with that type of personality behind mac
jones because you just don't know how
it's going to affect the young
quarterback and it could potentially
divide the locker room as well
does cam play
again
well he has to decide if he's okay with
being a backup quarterback because he's
not gonna be a starter in this league if
he wants to be a bridge quarterback or
if he wants to be say a backup
quarterback to someone
you know for uh a period of time then
yes but i don't see cam newton sign with
anyone and being their starter this year
next year or even the future
when's the last time you cracked up bill
belichick
cracked up like made him laugh
out well i just think the last time that
we we you know when i got inducted to
the hall of fame the patriots i think it
was two night 2019 we just had some you
know some old conversations and we
hugged and we smiled and we laughed and
and it was just good to see coach but i
think coach has done a really great job
of getting talent surrounding this young
man with talent you look at their
offensive line it's going to be good dan
they go four or five deep at the running
back position um they always have
special good special teams a better
defense i think their defense is going
to be top five top ten
and this kid is set up to succeed right
now and i believe that they can push
buffalo for that division i think
they're a playoff team for sure and i
agree that offensive line is going to be
one of the top five offensive lines
probably and then you have all those
running backs and it you got the tight
ends as well
it does feel like
sort of what they did with brady when
they put brady in there you guys had a
really good defense and
you know at the time bill's going
just don't don't lose a game for us it
felt like but go back to that super bowl
when tom wins his first
and instead of playing for overtime and
john madden famously during the game is
like you know
with with tom brady there they should be
playing for overtime brady comes out in
that two-minute drill you know leading
you down for vina terry's kick like
uh what was that like though on the
sidelines when all of a sudden you
realize belichick's letting brady
try to win this game
oh i think we froze up can you hear me
rod
ah
once again i thought i had a great
question and then he was really giving a
great thought there good setup too yeah
i know i know i know yes mclovin
patriots may be playing with the
equipment as they've been known to do
the video equipment maybe didn't want
him answering that oh
just
conspiracy theory
any time there's a negative patriots
story seton's always
have you ever agreed with any of the
negative stories seton about the
patriots where you go yeah i could see
that or i agree with that negative
stories yeah like what do you mean give
me an example
like deflategate oh it's
ideal gas law they had it explained
right away why hasn't the league ever
released the whole next year the league
spent a whole season testing all of the
footballs and their air pressure
rodney's back rodney's back it's bs i
think rod can you hear me
i can hear you dan okay take me back to
that first super bowl brady one
and when you guys are on the sidelines
and he's trying to win belichick's
letting him try to win that game instead
of going into overtime yeah dan think
about it tom's not built to try to tie
the game tom he's built his mindset is
no matter what situation that we're in
no matter what the circumstance is tom
brady is trying to win and that's the
confidence that we had in him you know
and that's why it didn't matter if you
see tom with 50 seconds 40 seconds a
minute two minutes these are things that
we've always worked on and that that's
when tom brady really shines in those
critical moments and that's the thing
that really separates him from everyone
else he's rodney harrison nbc football
night in america analyst two times super
bowl champ do you care about the pro
football hall of fame
um
i do um to a certain point
i believe that i i definitely um deserve
to be there
but also believe that you know in time
and when it's when it's my time i will
go you know i used to get caught up in
that guy how did he go and stuff like
that but at the end of the day it's not
even about that um it's about you know
when when it's ultimately my time to go
i know god's gonna lead the way and i'll
be happy with it who's the best
defensive back
in your opinion
in the league now no
that that you ever played against
i would say you have to put a guy like a
charm charles woodson in that category i
think you know charles over the course
of his career he's shown so much
versatility a guy that can play outside
he's played inside as a nickel as uh you
know he played as a linebacker he's
played as a deep safety so a guy like
that to be able to be that productive
over that many years and played
a multitude of positions i would think
that you know i would say when he
retired i called charles or texted him
through peter king was like hey i think
you're the greatest defensive back of
all time because he can do everything at
every single position like charles could
have been a pro bowler at every single
position in the secondary most
frustrating wide receiver that you faced
oh it had to be um jerry
it would be jerry rice and marvin
harrison because no matter how much you
hit marvin harris and how much you
jammed him that little dude was always
going to find a little way to get right
there in the openings and catch the ball
jerry rice because his relentlessness
his route running his consistency no
matter how hard you hit him he's going
to come right back across the middle and
look at you say that's all you got get
up and run back to the huddle so those
two guys are definitely the most
frustrating and you got fined for your
hit on jerry rice didn't you didn't you
yeah i got to find like a full game
check and that was back in like 98 i
think it was or 2001 and it got me for
about 150 grand man oh wow yeah yeah but
it was worth it it was worth it
now do you write the check or do they
take it out of your
your well just put it like this when you
go and they they're gonna find you a
game check basically you just don't
collect your check
you just don't have you just don't get
that check so it was just a a monday or
a tuesday that i just went in and said
hey i just don't get paid this week but
it was nice knocking his head off what
do you say to your wife when you say hun
uh not getting paid this week hey we
still got money
a roof over your head
uh
who do you like more the rams are the
chargers
um the ramps i think matthew snapper i
think he's going to do a great job um
can he get him to the super bowl we'll
see i mean he hasn't been in that
situation before but overall them as a
as a group i like the continuity i think
sean mcvay is a still a really solid um
head coach and i think that defense will
be good with aaron donald so i would
definitely give them you look at the
charges man the chargers over the years
they've had special teams issues they've
had penalties they've always been just
so um
injuries undisciplined it can't kick
field goals just all those different
things but i think slowly but surely
brandon staley will get this team back
to where they need to be and during
james coming back he's going to be
outstanding look for him to be defensive
player of the year
aaron rodgers more likely to stay or
less likely to stay
if the packers are successful
i would say i would say
if they're if they win a super bowl i
can say you know they'll probably extend
them and give them a big contract but if
they don't win the super bowl and it's
just really disrespectful from a packers
organization standpoint like no matter
how much aaron rodgers frustrates you
he's great
he's great and he doesn't deserve to be
treated the way they treated him how can
aaron rodgers ever go into a season
worrying about his contract
i mean how does that happen like he is
that great of a player where he should
never have to worry about his contract
like tom should have never had to worry
about his contract those dudes you take
care of because they love football
they're passionate about it they put
team first and they should be rewarded
and i just don't understand like who's
who's ever running the green bay packers
why would you even put your team in a
situation like this let alone aaron
rodgers having to to come out publicly
and it's it's all a distraction and your
goal is to win a super bowl
i think it's going to affect them going
into the season
well
if they gave him a heads up and said
we're drafting jordan love that doesn't
mean he was going to be happy that they
were drafting jordan love
i think they were
they were betting on aaron rodgers you
know his numbers were going to continue
to drop he had had two
subpar seasons for him and they thought
okay the end is near we're going to
draft jordan love um i understand what
their logic was
but can you give him a heads up that
you're going to be drafting a
quarterback
or well even if even if you do or if you
don't you still have to go to him out of
respect and to me if i'm an organization
if i'm running an organization as a
general manager i'm pulling aaron to the
side and i'm letting them know hey our
plan is this our plan is to draft this
young man let him learn two or three
years behind you and let you do your
thing and by that what i'm going to do
is i'm going to come and we're going to
do a new contract to let you know that
that's our intention but they didn't do
that with aaron rodgers they didn't show
him the respect or the loyalty that he
deserved and he had a right to be pissed
off i've been working on my belichick
impersonation let me see it
uh rodney uh
i think you're a hall of famer it's
great to talk to you and uh i wish you
the best uh mvc i'm glad that that uh
guy dan patrick's not on there anymore
so uh just uh i want to wish you a good
season okay dan that is spot on
especially the part about he said he
wished
[Laughter]
i i tell that the audience and the den
at that time we were at uh the jets game
patriots jets might have been the butt
fumble and belichick comes out of the
tunnel and you and tony dungy are there
and he's like shaking your hands and and
then i was next in line and then he just
while he walked right by me
hey i had the same experience i think it
was in dominic and sue he walked up to
coach and you know i had said some
things about him in the past and i'm on
the sideline and he walks up to me and
he shakes coach hands and i'm looking at
the biggest guy i've ever seen in my
life one of the toughest meanest dudes
i'm like i hope this dude just doesn't
backslap me
and he gave me the dirtiest look that
walked away i was like god bless i'm
glad i'm okay
hey great to talk to you as always uh
good luck this season thank you again
for joining us buddy anytime dan good to
see you bro thank you man that's rodney
harrison nbc football night in america
won uh back-to-back super bowls there